guillermo del toro's work so could you
just talk to us because i've met
guillermo at a few events and he's
absolutely adorable can you just talk to
us about
guillermo the man guillermo the director
what he's like to work with because i'm
sure people would would just eat that up
yeah no guillermo del toro is the he's
my favorite director i've ever worked
with and every other director knows that
going in and they're fine with it
because they all love him too
uh so he he as a as an artist he is you
know of course he's a brilliant genius
uh he he has he has ingested art forms
all of his life and whether it's
painting sculptures music dance theater
uh
literature film television of course
he's he's taken all of it in and he has
this huge encyclopedia to draw from
uh he also is is the the
he is such a
learner and absorber of people when he
meets you he has you sussed up in within
minutes uh what makes you tick and what
buttons to push to get reactions out of
you and as a director with an actor
that's a brilliant art uh you know gift
to have
so he he directs all of us actors very
differently from each other even like
you know when i'm playing opposite ron
perlman and selma blair we all have
different personalities and different
things that that will trigger a a
reaction or you know or a piece of
direction out of us
uh so he he knows how to
do that and get into your into your
psyche in a in a very healthy way though
[Music]